fala
ó
o corpo só foi devolvida mas o vídeo e
hoje vou ensinar como fazer uma pistola
que eles para te fez elásticos ela
dispara pessoais mas determinado a usar
quatro então cinco isso porque para
manterem os latics todos esta robinho
tem dar uma volta quase 360 graus e como
vocês podem ver que uma parte inclusive
lahnstein passa por dentro então é
complicado manter todos então eu
recomendo que vocês cursos em quatro
então cinco e mais para frente vocês por
terem destruído ou fazer outros modelos
criticaram mais elásticos e com
metralhadoras
é este tipo de coisas aí uma coisa de
começar eu queria só falar o tipo plano
que estou usar ela assim maicon passado
e comprei uma portaria e tem mais ou
menos de dois mil litros
agora se vocês não quiserem comprar o
podem fazer é usar aquelas caixas de
cereais de pequeno almoço que tem mais
ou menos de um milímetro e quando for
usar uma camada de um tempo população
vocês têm que usar duas camadas de
exportação de cereais de pequeno-almoço
aí você expõe duas lá em casa eu porque
uma e fazem assim até o final ou seja no
final vocês vão ter o dobro das camadas
que este arma tem mas vai dar o mesmo e
só então nos conquistar
a primeira coisa que vocês têm que fazer
em primeiro e se tem um pleito que vocês
vão encontrar carga no primeiro link da
inscrição e depois lá no facebook tem
carga na secção das fotografias e
procurar pela imagem a seguir vocês têm
que dividir utilizar as peças que vou
encontrar na vossa folha e depois claro
em pedaços de papelão e fita para
aprender mas se vocês quiserem podem
usar cola button
o então podem por folha por cima e
depois contornar as linhas utilizando
uma caneta ou então um lápis
depois vocês ao pressionarem vão
conseguir marcar o plano por baixo
continuar em folha vocês vão conseguir
ver as linhas
só que o inconveniente disso é que você
pode fazer em três ou quatro módulos
as linhas vão estragar passar tantas
vezes com caneta por cima depois os
modos vão ficar ligeiramente norte
se vocês quiserem ter um modo bem feito
e mesmo podem fazer desta maneira o
então podem fazer da outra mães por
conter mais trabalho com uma lixa e que
estou usar sete camadas mas vocês usarem
população que eu falei no início vão ter
que usar mais o mdic tours
e no final é sempre importante vocês
porém o peso por cima para que as
camadas fiquem bem compactas
estou agora usar uma mini arte fica mas
se vocês não tiverem não tem problema
nenhum de vocês podem usar o lixa que
serve perfeitamente
agora vou fazer e que seis pecinhas
nestas que é para o gatilho
vejo que marquei tamanho os furos
obesidade má carlos for só uma pecinha
pecinha que ficar por cima
eu vou colocando isso usar agora cola
teve a mas se vocês quiserem podem usar
outras escolas como aquelas rua gaúchos
culares é muito importante vocês
deixarem bem e esta peça vai por dentro
então convém ficar muito bem forte e se
vocês quiserem podem por cola a volta
nestas partes inclui que usa e mirthe
ficar ok
para ficar ainda mais resistente agora
vou fazer 33 linhas e vou usar agora
quatro bombinhas no design vocês têm
duas bolinhas com tamanhos de frente o
eu era pra fazer uma coisa só que acabei
mudando e da este ficaram as duas
bolinhas lá desenhadas é mas eu fazer
isso mais para frente sexta e eu tiver
um filho é positivo em outros modelos e
vai ocorrer duas bolinhas de um lado e
depois duas bolinhas do outro lado
agora vou fazer um furo no centro quando
isto se cara a gente estava marcado
você não consegue ver muito bem postado
na marcação e é mesmo importante que
vocês façam isso for mesmo bem
centralizado até aí é preciso fazer duas
duas coisas destas cinco atrás dos
móveis atrás
se vocês acharem que ficou fraco então
podem enfrentar mais placas laterais
eu fiz dois furos na mesa porque eu
posso em uma mesa do trabalho agora
vocês não façam isso lá em casa que
depois vão ter problemas com os vossos
pais é eu fiz isso para testar o
mecanismo antes de fechar a arma tipo
escola
depois é só encaixar e fica tudo no
sítio certo desta maneira
agora se vocês quiserem testar o nosso
organismo é só fazer isso em cima de um
pedaço de mim
lá fora a cair frontal mas já está feito
agora estou a lixar tudo para ficar tudo
bonitinho usar o x aa também postar umas
partes
se vocês quiserem pintar eu recomendo
que passa uma camada de cola pva por
cima da arma toda a gente cá e depois
podem passar mais um clinch e depois com
os paraíbas fica muito bonita é não que
eu puxei muito na pintura de estar no
terreno na parte técnica estar muito é
porque minha ideia era mesmo
experimentar a este tipo de gatilho mas
mais para frente estou a pensar começar
a pintar as minhas armas
agora vejam que estou bem e estou
colocada agora tem um centímetro e meio
de cada lado de fora e isso é muito
importante que vai ajudar depois na hora
de ter oscilado picos
vou colocar agora um elástico que é
muito importante e tem que ficar bem
esticado e vejam que eu tenho um sítio
especial que eu fiz pra vocês colocarem
eu agora vou enxergar como eu disse no
início e o nome de um punho site por
quatro então cinco que mais fácil e por
um só chegamos enfim muito obrigado
investidos vocês curtiram deste tipo de
armas e querem que eu evolua mais este
gênero e faça mais bonitas então deixei
o vosso laico e isso ajuda bastante dele
os meus projetos e isso tem alguma
sugestão podem deixar os comentários que
eu lá e faça as coisas que achar mais
bacanas e produção do filme muito
obrigado investido até a próxima à iii
vocês fizeram mesmo usando óculos de
proteção cai por pessoal nunca de
martins tomar